I was diagnosed with a condition called POTS
when I was just 15 years old,
and it's been 10 years of trying to figure out what works best for me.
My body just does not retain water very well,
and that's why it's so important to have a good electrolyte drink
to drink through the day for my body to help retain fluid.
Salty is a really great option for this.
I really want to remain active even with my condition,
and have tried to do so
by playing volleyball and pickleball throughout the years.
I still want to be active in my daily life
no matter what my condition is,
and that's why having a good electrolyte drink is so important to me.
The other thing I love about salty is that it is paleo,
vegan, and keto.
It tastes so good. Thank you, salty,
for helping me stay active.